the overwhelming majority of Pilots are
human beings for now and because of that
flying can be kind of a dangerous
business and that's why the FAA requires
new pilots to learn about stuff that
affects us human beings when we go fly
and that's exactly what we're going to
be talking about in today's free Private
Pilot ground lesson from free pilot
training
[Music]
welcome to Free pilot training I'm Josh
and today we're going to start out by
talking about how stupid human beings
can be people are just too stupid to
accept me as their leader it's too bad
you can't make people smarter that's
that's brilliant cool it is absolutely
pinky are you pondering what I'm
pondering oh I'd say the odds of that
are terribly slim brain true I mean
really when have I ever been pondering
what you've been pondering to my
knowledge never exactly so what are the
chances that this time I'm pondering
what you're pondering next to Neil now I
know this is funny but the truth is we
all have our moments when we do stupid
stuff and that's because we're human
beings but we can minimize the amount of
mistakes that we make if we know a few
things about the human body and our
minds to kick things off let's talk a
little bit about our vision and how to
use it to avoid running into other
aircraft one of the first things you're
going to notice when you start learning
how to fly is how difficult it is to
spot other air traffic and as you might
have guessed this is extremely important
if you don't want to run into another
aircraft but there is a technique that
makes it a little bit easier to spot
those guys according to the FAA the
absolute best way to scan for other
aircraft is to use a series of short
regularly spaced eye movements as you
begin scanning Focus your vision at a
point in space about 10 degrees in front
of the last point until you move all the
way across your field of view each time
you move your focus to a new spot you
should keep your focus there for at
least one second before moving on to the
next spot don't just sweep your eyes
across the field of view it's going to
be much more difficult to spot other
traffic that way because you're only
using your photopic vision or your
focused Vision when you do that
pausing briefly forces you to use your
peripheral vision and this is really
important because you'll spot relative
movement way faster with your peripheral
vision than you will with your photopic
vision
during straight and level flight most
Pilots prefer to scan horizontally or go
back and forth using these 10 degree
segments like I just mentioned this is
going to allow you to see the relative
movement from converging traffic from a
bunch of different directions but if you
find something that works a little bit
better for you use that technique and
stick with it just remember you'll spot
relative movement way faster with your
peripheral vision
but what if you spot another aircraft
and you don't see any relative movement
what would that indicate remember no
relative movement means that you are
likely on a collision course for that
aircraft if you don't do something to
fix that really fast you could end up
dead
the groundhog will be bringing you your
mail know what I mean situations like
this where two aircraft are on a
collision course can be particularly
dangerous because when there's no
relative movement it's way more
difficult to spot another aircraft and
that's because your peripheral vision
can't pick up that movement you have to
spot the other aircraft with your
photopic vision and that's another
reason why we use those 10 degree
segments that gives us the best chance
to focus in and spot that aircraft
because this Focus area of our vision is
limited to about 5 to 10 degrees
night operations add some additional
limitations that you should be aware of
as a pilot using your peripheral vision
is even more important at night because
the cones in your eyes which are
responsible for photopic visions do not
work well at night
as you can see we actually have a blind
spot in that area at night which keeps
us from focusing because of that you
have to primarily rely on your
peripheral vision when it's dark outside
and if you want to look at something you
have to use your peripheral vision to do
that as well we call this off-center
viewing
as you might have guessed scanning with
10 degree segments is even more
important at night because of the loss
of our photopic vision and you have to
be very Vigilant because if there's no
relative movement another aircraft can
be extremely difficult to spot at night
because of that we want to have the best
night vision possible when we go fly and
one of the best ways to do that is to
prep your eyes for nightfly the rods in
your eyes are responsible for your
peripheral vision and night vision and
they work great but they need a little
time to adapt to the darkness when
you're flying at night you should avoid
bright lights for at least 30 minutes
before you go fly especially bright
white flashing lights these will destroy
your night vision in a heartbeat now
something else you should keep in mind
when it comes to scanning for traffic is
visibility
I know this might seem obvious but
anytime it's hazy outside this can
create an optical illusion Haze can make
it seem like other traffic and even
terrain is farther away than it actually
is and I don't have to tell you how
dangerous that could possibly be the
side of a mountain is not particularly
forgiving when you run into it
[Music]
so anytime we fly in Haze or at night it
can be particularly dangerous when
trying to spot other aircraft but oddly
enough most collisions actually happen
on nice days when it's clear outside
maybe that's because there are more
pilots flying when it's nice outside but
it could also be because Pilots get
complacent and forget to use good
scanning techniques either one is a good
reason to pay attention and use these
techniques we just talked about but what
should I do if I make a mistake and I do
accidentally get too close to another
aircraft or on purpose because I'm an
idiot remember according to far 9113 it
doesn't matter if you're flying under
VFR or IFR as long as the weather
conditions permit every person operating
an aircraft must maintain vigilance so
as to see and avoid other aircraft now
one way you can do that is to pay
attention to areas that commonly have
lots of air traffic and one particular
spot that the FAA wants you to know
about is over the top of a VOR and in
areas where Victor Airways intercept
if you're working on your private Palace
license you may not know what a Victor
Airway even is but take a look at these
blue lines here on the VFR sectional
that are shooting off from the Fort
Smith VOR
these are basically little highways for
people who are flying under instrument
flight rules
let's take a quick glance at the IFR low
charts for this area
I know this might be a little bit
difficult to read if you've never seen
one of these charts before
but these roots are commonly used
because they've been surveyed to give
Pilots clearance from terrain and
obstacles and they help ATC predict the
path an instrument pilot is going to
take because of that it's very common to
have IFR traffic on these little
highways but I want you to notice
something each one of these vor's is
basically an intersection for all these
little highways so let me ask you a
question when you're learning how to
drive where did they tell you to pay
special attention when you're driving so
you don't run into another car at an
intersection right as you can see you
can have a bunch of different Victor
Airways going in and out of a VOR
in addition to that some of these
Airways actually intersect between two
vor's like you see down here at blurb
and Daniel
so these can be important areas to pay
attention to as well and if we flip back
over to the VFR sectional you'll notice
these little points are often depicted
with these little arrows on the Victor
Airways anyway if you do accidentally
get too close to another aircraft the
FAA refers to this as a near midair
collision and a near mid-air Collision
is when you miss another aircraft by
less than 500 feet
if you get this close you need to let
ATC know as soon as possible if you
aren't on the radio with these guys you
can also call them up on the phone once
you get on the ground you can also
report a near midair Collision to the
nearest flight service station by using
the radio or the phone
and another option is to file a report
in writing to your local physio office
but I don't really recommend that
because you want to let someone know as
soon as possible so it doesn't happen
again
and that's the whole point in reporting
these things to ATC the intent is not to
get you in trouble is to keep this from
happening to someone else because the
FAA can review the tapes and use them
for training and figure out ways to make
things safer for everyone okay let's
move on to talk about hypoxia and
hyperventilation these are both really
important topics that every pilot needs
to know about let's talk about hypoxia
first the word hypoxia literally means
reduced oxygen or not enough oxygen and
as you might have guessed if you don't
have enough oxygen some bad stuff starts
to happen no if your body doesn't have
enough oxygen the tissue in your body
can actually start to die if it goes
without oxygen too long but the more
immediate danger is what happens in the
brain any reduction in oxygen can reduce
your brain's ability to think and make
decisions and some of you guys can't
afford any reduction in your thinking
capacity yes that's it
pinky are you pondering what I'm
pondering
what's outline but it's but it's a call
that this one grew
back I'm just kidding it doesn't matter
how smart you are if your brain isn't
getting enough oxygen you could easily
make all kinds of bad decisions it could
even cause you to pass out and in both
situations you could potentially crash
and die and I'm sure that no one here
wants that I hope anyway there are a few
different types of hypoxia that can
affect you as a pilot but the main one
you need to be familiar with is hypoxic
hypoxia
oddly enough as you climb higher and
higher on your aircraft the percentage
of oxygen in the air doesn't change but
there's less air pressure up there and
because of that there's less oxygen up
at higher altitudes for you to breathe
but at what altitude should I start
getting concerned about hypoxia and what
should I do if I'm going to fly above
that altitude according to the FAA in
Far 91 to 11 if you're going to be
flying at a cabin altitude above 12 500
feet for more than 30 minutes you are
required to have and use supplemental
oxygen if you're going to be flying
above 14 000 you have to have and use it
the whole time now keep in mind every
regulation that was ever written Was
Written in Blood we have these rules for
a reason but the truth is you can
develop hypoxic hypoxia as low as 10 000
feet so if you're flying up here at
these higher altitudes pay attention to
your body and use oxygen or descend if
you think you're getting hypoxic
even if you're not all the way up at 12
500 feet okay but high altitude isn't
the only thing that can cause you to get
hypoxic another type of hypoxia that you
should be aware of is hypemic hypoxia
this occurs when the blood in your body
can't transport enough oxygen to the
cells in your body this can happen if
your blood has been poisoned by carbon
monoxide
carbon monoxide can literally block the
blood's ability to carry oxygen and when
you get large accumulations of carbon
monoxide in the blood it can keep your
body tissues and brain from getting the
oxygen they need and just like high
altitude this can cause you to make bad
decisions or even pass out it's a lot
harder to fly an airplane when you're
asleep but where would you get carbon
monoxide poisoning engine exhaust is the
biggest culprit when it comes to carbon
monoxide poisoning if your exhaust
system has a leak in it or if your
heating system has a leak in it this can
allow carbon monoxide to enter the
cockpit because most cockpit heaters use
a heat exchanger off the engine exhaust
system because of this you'll often see
these simple carbon monoxide detectors
in the cockpit of your aircraft to let
you know if that crap is sneaking in to
make you go night night my advice is
that anytime you feel weird look down
and make sure this thing is not telling
you that there's carbon monoxide in the
cabin because hypoxia can affect anyone
and usually strange feelings are some of
the first indications that you're in
danger one other thing to keep in mind
is that your body is more susceptible to
hypermic hypoxia when you're at high
altitudes and that's because your body
is getting less air because you're at
high altitude and if your oxygen
carrying capacity is being crippled by
carbon monoxide these effects can
compound and make things really bad
now let's talk about hyperventilation
this one's way more common than you
might think and it could also lead into
a dangerous situation if you don't know
how to recognize it or fix the problem
oddly enough the symptoms for
hyperventilation are very similar to
hypoxia
hyperventilating can cause you to get
disoriented and make all kinds of bad
decisions and there's even a possibility
of passing out from that as well because
of that it's very important that you pay
attention and diagnose it properly
hyperventilation is caused by excessive
breathing which cause your body to get
rid of too much carbon dioxide
now I know this seems kind of weird
since oxygen is the stuff we breathe in
and that's what keeps us alive but we
also need to keep a small amount of
carbon dioxide in our blood as well
because that helps the blood carry
oxygen and it also tells your body that
it needs to breathe because of that if
any person gets too excited and speeds
up their breathing too much because of
stress fear or any kind of other
emotional tension they become at risk
for hyperventilation and if this happens
to someone in your aircraft all you need
to do is slow down that person's
breathing there are a couple ways you
can do that one you can start talking to
them and trying to calm them down you
can make them talk out loud which will
force them to take fewer breaths or
there's always the trusty old paper bag
if you force them to breathe into a
paper bag that will help them slow their
breathing down and that'll keep the
carbon dioxide in their system remember
use a paper bag plastic bags are bad for
the environment and other reasons and as
a result it does take quite a long time
to make change evenly the best one in
the world
now that you know about hyperventilation
and hypoxia let's talk about another
silent killer spatial disorientation
spatial disorientation is something that
can happen when your brain tells you
that your airplane is doing something
different than it actually is
in case you didn't know your body has
three different systems that work
together to tell your brain where your
body is in space these are the
vestibular system somatosensory system
and the visual system when your body's
walking or moving around on the ground
these three systems work together to
give your brain information on your
body's orientation and space
it's important to remember that the
human body was not meant to fly and
because of that these different systems
get conflicting information your brain
can get confused and tell you that your
airplane is doing something that's
completely different than it actually is
now probably the most important system
in your body that gives your brain
information on its orientation is your
visual system
because if you can see outside your
brain can still make sense of a lot of
conflicting information that may be
being sent by the other organs in your
inner ear or some other system so the
real dangerous situations happen when
the visibility starts getting bad
outside here are a few examples of some
of the illusions that could occur if
your brain is getting conflicting
information and the visibility outside
the cockpit is really bad
now I'm not going to go over each one of
these in detail but let's look at the
most common illusion that you're most
likely to encounter the leans this
illusion can occur if you're making a
gentle turn in One Direction at less
than two degrees per second if you level
the wings too quickly after the turn
your brain is very likely to tell you
that you've made a turn in the opposite
direction the reason for this is because
your body can have difficulty filling
the fluid in your inner ears move when
the turn is less than two degrees per
second
and when you roll out too quickly your
brain thinks it went from Level flight
to a turn in the opposite direction with
that in mind if you get into this
situation if you can look outside and
verify what's actually happening the
problems basically solve but if you're
in instrument conditions and you can't
see outside the cockpit you could get
discombobulated really easily that's why
Pilots should never trust those signals
that your brain is giving you use your
instruments that's the exact reason why
you're required to get three hours of
instrument training when you're getting
your private pass license take a look at
your instruments and Trust what they're
telling you your brain is a liar and it
will kill you at the first chance it
gets do it the next topic can be just a
little bit dry but I want you to pay
close attention because it's actually
super important if you're weird and like
staying alive for some reason now I want
to show you something from the Airman
certification standards which is the
document that outlines how you'll be
graded on your check ride notice that
for everything you do the FAA wants you
to use something called risk management
now why on Earth would they care about
that unless they thought it was an
important part of being a pilot well
I'll tell you everything you do in life
has a risk for example there's always a
risk of choking every time you sit down
at the dinner table to eat
but we don't quit eating because there's
a risk of choking no we accept that risk
and we do our best to minimize that risk
by chewing our food 28 times or whatever
your mom told you to do the same thing
goes for flying airplanes we know there
are risks but if we can identify what
those risks are then we can take steps
to reduce those risks when we go fly and
that's the key to not dying and once
again I enjoy not dying it's tough to
fly airplanes when you're dead anyway
here are four categories of risks that
the FAA wants you to know about and if
you can remember these it can help you
start to make some good decisions about
the risks you're taking and this is what
we're talking about when we talk about
aeronautical decision making or ADM okay
who thought of this acronym pave V is
literally in the middle of the word
environment I'm never going to remember
that how about we use I need to take a p
I bet you'll never forget that one
anyway our aircraft is our first element
of risk now as a general rule aircraft
are pretty reliable they have to go
through extensive certification and
inspections before you can legally fly
them and that really helps reduce our
risk but there are still risks involved
and every aircraft has different risks
associated with it for example if I fly
an older aircraft it's probably not
going to have the performance it did
when it was new if I've got plenty of
runway in front of me this risk isn't
really a big deal but if the poh says I
need 865 feet of Runway but my airplane
is 57 years old and I have 900 feet in
front of me I should use my aeronautical
decision making skills and say that I'm
not going to take that risk it just
doesn't make much sense the next risk
element is the pilot this one is
extremely important for you to remember
because pilot air is the number one
cause of accidents when it comes to
flying let's look at an example of how
the pilot could be a risk element let's
say I want to start learning to fly a
tail dragger if I haven't received the
proper training there's a good chance I
could ground Loop the aircraft now the
FAA has helped us out a little bit by
forcing us to get a tail wheel
endorsement before we can just jump in
and go fly but what if you got your tail
wheel endorsement and you didn't fly one
again for a year the risk of a ground
Loop is higher because you're not
proficient in the aircraft a good
aeronautical decision for you to make
would be to get with an instructor and
get a little training before you just
jumped in and took an unnecessary risk
okay so the next element of risk is the
environment do you think that the
weather can cause risks absolutely it
can that's why the weather is such an
important part of flying if you know
what the weather is where you're flying
and you know the rules it's a lot easier
to make good decisions
next we have external pressures and I'm
not talking about the pressure that
crushed that submarine that was
exploring the Titanic
I'm talking about pressure to go ahead
and take the fly even if it doesn't make
much sense to do so
maybe you're trying to go to a wedding
or some other kind of event and the
weather just isn't cooperating you could
feel pressure just to go ahead and risk
it and this pressure can come from other
people or even yourself but this has
ended in death and disaster for many
Pilots it's just not worth it guys take
a step back and evaluate the risks and
make good decisions remember Human air
is the biggest reason for aircraft
accidents and that's as those Pilots
either fail to recognize the risks in a
situation or they made a bad decision
because they had a dangerous attitude
towards that risk and this raises an
important question what are some
dangerous attitudes that we could have
that could cause us to make a bad
decision the FAA refers to these as the
five hazardous attitudes that can hurt
our aeronautical decision making
now these are really important for you
guys to be aware of because if you look
at risk management and you have one of
these attitudes towards that risk you're
very likely to get yourself into trouble
for example let's say someone grew up
riding in the front seat of their
Grandpa's Stearman but they never
actually got their tailwell endorsement
they may have an anti-authority attitude
don't tell me I need a tail will
endorsement I grew up in a tail dragger
I'm flying
I'm pilot
and then they die because they didn't
actually know how to land that thing
they just saw their grandpa do it and if
you ever find yourself with one of these
attitudes remind yourself of the
antidote for anti-authority the antidote
is follow the rules they're usually
right
maybe you have a tendency to be
impulsive do it now and ask questions
later do it this is one I struggle with
the antidote for this one is not so fast
think first the Air Force has a saying
about this one slow is fast it seems
dumb but it's very true often a quick
decision is a wrong one
maybe you feel invulnerable sometimes
that would never happen to me let me
tell you something even experienced
Pilots get reminders that it could
easily happen to you I've scared the
crap out of myself on more than one
occasion and in many cases I wasn't
actually doing anything wrong I just
accepted more risk than I should have
here's an interesting one Macho you have
to be careful about this one because
becoming a pilot requires quite a bit of
confidence but it's extremely important
to start learning your limits as a pilot
remember there are old pilots and there
are bold Pilots but there are no old
bold Pilots
if something seems dangerous it probably
is there are a million resources out
there to improve your skills and reduce
risk
the antidote for this one is Taking
Chances is foolish and that's the
mindset you should always have
next is resignation there may be times
when you get yourself into a situation
where things seem hopeless maybe your
engine takes a dump on you or something
one of the worst attitudes you can
develop is what's the use I'm dead no
matter what
attitudes like this can contribute to
some of the most dangerous situations if
you ever feel like things are hopeless
or you're not in control of a situation
immediately apply the antidote I'm not
helpless I can make a difference
attitudes like this can get you into all
kinds of dangerous situations these can
cause you to exceed your abilities as a
pilot or even the capabilities of the
aircraft maybe you want to land on a
short Runway and the airplane is capable
of a ground roll of 600 feet you never
practice short filled Landings but
there's a field you want to land on
that's 900 feet long a macho pilot might
say I can do anything I never have bad
Landings
okay but you also haven't practiced
short field Landings in a while
taking that chance is foolish
what if I'm flying in class golf
airspace and the visibility is down to
one statute mile should I keep going or
should I turn around and find better
weather people get spatially disoriented
all the time by continuing to fly into
IFR conditions when they knew they
should have just turned around aopa has
a really sobering video that I like to
share with my students about a Private
Pilot that did this exact thing
you should really watch it if you get
the chance it's pretty crazy before I
leave you today I do want to leave you
with one final thought as a pilot your
main job is to identify risks and make
good decisions about those risks you
will never completely eliminate risk
when it comes to Flying that's just the
nature of Aviation and I guess it's part
of what makes flying fun but as you
continue to learn and improve your
skills you need to reduce risk as much
as possible before flying and you can do
this a few different ways first you can
do this by maintaining good situational
awareness and this simply means paying
attention if your head's up your rear
end and you aren't focused on flying the
airplane and you're not looking outside
for traffic you can get yourself into
trouble really fast you also need to
recognize when there's a problem if the
engine's running rough and you just
continue to fly your cross country
without troubleshooting the problem or
turning around you may get to practice
your emergency Landings how neat is that
then you gotta use good judgment let's
say I switched to my left tank and my
engine starts cutting out what should I
do well don't switch to the left tank go
back to the right tank and consider the
left tank unusable
use common sense guys you'd be amazed at
how uncommon that is these days but it's
very effective remember as the pilot in
command you are responsible for the safe
operation of that aircraft even if you
need to break a rule to ensure the
safety of others that might be just what
you have to do in order to get everyone
on board safely on the ground thanks for
watching free pilot training if you
enjoyed this video it means a lot when
you guys hit that like button it helps
the algorithm or something I don't know
anyway do that if you would and then
continue studying with this video right
here
sip
[Music]